The medical model that might begin to
talk about this problem based model is,
is really restricted.
It,
it's very powerful and it helps us,
but,
but it only takes us so far.
The fundamental nature of dying is not
medical,
it's personal.
And so,
you know,
dying cannot be encompassed by a set of
medical problems and a set of diagnoses
and treatments.
Um,
so while we,
while we can,
can remain disease focused,
um,
for as long as it makes sense,
we also have to attend to the personal
aspects of dying of people.
You know,
the,
what you lose and dying in the hospital
many times is you lose that personal
time.
Your,
your,
your space is not your own people walk
in and out.
Um,
you don't have the sort of privacy or
intimacy with family.
Beyond that though we stayed within that
medical model.
Everybody who walks in your room or
interacts with you are talking to you
about medical problems.
They will continue to conscript your
attention to the lab tests and the next,
uh,
scans and the next treatments and the
drugs and your vital signs and all of
that.
Um,
instead of attending to the personal,
they actually conscript your time and
energy for the medical,
the best end of life care that I know of
through modeled by hospice programs and,
and the best palliative care programs
still does all the medical stuff,
but it's subordinated to the personal.
It's,
it's,
you know,
in hospice care,
we make appointments to see you and your
family and not the other way around.
We're coming to your home.
We are,
um,
uh,
explicitly acknowledging the importance
of Interactions,
um,
of your privacy and intimacy.
And beyond that we're even offering some
help,
some guidance that may be a value to you
in this area of,
of human interaction.
I would call life completion in life
closure,
you know,
which again,
in a problem based medical model doesn't
even exist.
It's not their quality of life and
quality of life completion really exists
in a,
in a developmental model that really
honors the,
the breadth of human life for the person
and family,
but,
but not in a problem based model.
So even the very best of of a problem
based medicine and including attention
to symptoms in the like tends not to see
those personal experiences of completing
one's affairs,
fiscal and legal and project related
affairs,
but also their personal affairs,
their,
their relationships and their
explorations of the own meaning and
significance of their own life,
their relationship to something larger
than themselves.
That stuff that's not abstract for
people who know that,
that their life is measured in weeks or
days.
It's,
it's very tangible.